so a little over a year ago we launched
the world's best online budgeting app
it's called
every dollar you can get it at every
dollar calm and at the time we launched
it we launched it with an iPhone app a
free download to which all the Android
users in the world began to gripe at me
for the last year and a half because
they did not have an Android app and
went on and on and on and on some of you
were rather abusive about your Android
use I'm glad you have an Android and I'm
glad you're happy with your Android but
I'm apparently stupid and an inept
businessman because we did not launch
the app with an Android according to
some of you I'll go back and recap just
for the fun of it just because I can and
it's called the Dave Ramsey show we do
detailed metrics as to who uses what
tool when they're interacting with us 80
some odd percent of the interaction with
our store and our website is iOS meaning
it's an iPad or an iPhone I understand
that 80 percent of the general public
does not use an iPhone or iOS that the
Android actually has more users than the
iPhone does I understand that but if for
use of interfacing with us and with our
store we were serving our primary
customers first because it costs
hundreds of thousands of dollars to
develop one of these apps and on average
in any platform that you study anywhere
I mean there's very rare exceptions and
our people do detailed research we know
what we're doing we're not beginners the
iPhone user spins about four times as
much money as the Android user spins now
I don't know what that's attributable to
I'm not accusing you people being cheap
but you don't spend as much which is
fine that makes you a Dave Ramsey
follower that's awesome that's great
but it's harder to monetize having spent
millions and millions of dollars
developing something that we give away
for free called every dollar if you
don't buy anything
we're not mad about that we gave it away
for free we're fine so the point was we
didn't think we would ever get an ROI in
the next five years on the development
of an Android app the money is not there
it's that simple it's not because we
don't like you and it's not because but
it's also not because we're stupid it's
quite the opposite as a matter of fact
we did detailed metrics in spite of all
of that we have developed the Android
app and it went live today
so you Android users now have full
access to every dollar for free
awesomeness we probably will never
monetize on your butt but it's okay
we're going to serve you anyway we love
you we think you're awesome and if you
buy something it'll be awesome too but
in the meantime go use the free tool get
yourself out of debt and be part of this
revolution to change America and we want
you to do that all of you and some of
you are just incredibly smart according
to your own tweets so um the rest of
you're just having fun with me and we're
joking about it and we're having all
kinds of cool stuff and but it's amazing
it's I mean you put out a free app and
the first thing you get are people
saying the things you ought to fix about
it I miss the part where I mean it's
like your mama made you a free meal you
don't gripe about the squash Sun you eat
the squash you know it's free you stop
by and eat at somebody's house and make
cheese man what is up with the Twitter
whining it's amazing so anyway it's been
a fun day we've had a blast a lot of you
are saying very nice things and
congratulatory things and then we're
thankful for all of that but I in all my
years in business I've never been called
a doofus as much as I have over this I
mean I've done some things that were
doofus that deserved more heat than this
but not having an Android app apparently
was the sin beyond all sins in the
technology world so it is now solved
thank goodness
got that monkey off my back I'm no
longer stupid you took me off okay so
one and a half million people are now
using every dollar it's now available on
Android so that should shoot up
substantially by the end of the day so
whether you've got an iPhone or an
Android you can budget you can make your
money behave you can take care of things
you can get yourself out of debt imagine
what you could do with your money if you
finally took control of your money
I mean when you pay off all those debts
that means you can like save towards
retirement or go on vacation and pay
cash for it this is stuff that's real so
create your free every dollar budget at
every dollar calm takes less than 10
minutes for your iPhone and now for your
Android so what are you waiting for all
the blockers are out of your life you
got nothing to gripe at but yourself so
go get yourself out of debt get yourself
on a budget and do it for free and
you'll love it and it'll be awesome and
I feel so much better now got that out
of my life good and now they can deal
let every dollar people deal with all
the iterations and the updates and the
all the platform adjustments and all the
other things we're doing to continue to
keep the thing cutting-edge and robust
and robust that's a cool internet term
for those of you that don't know they
taught me that the other day hey guys
thanks for watching if you enjoyed this
video click the subscribe button to get
the latest content and check out these
other great clips from the show so you
have to break the cycle you have to flip
this thing on its head and make it
behave you've got to get so fired up and
wired up that you're broke friends think
you've lost your mind
you